we're in Minako the principality in the
cottager the rich and the beautiful have
long flocked to its shores
and it's also one of the more
spectacular venues for Formula One
racing but it's not just the latest
models you'll see speeding down the
asphalt circuit here since 1997 Minako
has also hosted series that features
historic motor cars which take place
every two years the star of this year's
event is this Auto Union type-c Grand
Prix race car from 1936 it puts out a
phenomenal 520 horsepower with just a
6-liter engine a five-speed transmission
in the rear and a differential located
between the engine and the rear axle
power the rear wheels jacky ickx
eight-time Formula one champion and
six-time winner the 24 Hours of lamont
will be behind the wheel
a lot of physical level
there is no power steering assistance
like we used to have today or brake
assistance so it's demanding and I think
it's a great privilege to drive it
especially around Monaco and it's also a
truck who is very demanding for those
already compete with not my case today
but if you imagine Formula One today
there is nothing like it you just can't
flirt with the rails it has to be
accurate and no mistakes allowed so that
makes a legend of Monaco another thing
that makes Minako so special is the
proximity of the spectators to the
racetrack
four-time Formula One world champion a
lamppost is completely smitten with the
ambience here the track is still the
same you know even if it's being had
some changes still the same ambience
same atmosphere so you when you see the
cars drivers the old rivals or the
mechanics engineers you know it's the
old history of motor racing and a
nonaqueous part of this we're not
arresting so in fact it looks like it's
normal you know but it's fantastic to
see they're such nice cars you know I'm
very impressed about the all the drivers
there they can be so I mean pushing out
the cars and being so fast and for sure
they are the respect of the the cars but
they also like to to go at the maximum
quite nicely the vintage cars champions
of yesteryear and the special flair
Monaco all combined to make it a
one-of-a-kind event but the historic
race cars and legendary racetrack also
exerts its pull on the younger
generation
it's got to be up there as one of the
top events when else you get a chance to
race on such an iconic historic circuit
it's driving between the barriers with
cars like these that are so fast tick
and there what's fun with these cars as
was there are they still move around a
lot on the limit you've got quite over
Syria cars very low grip surface being
at Road most of the time it's fantastic
another racing legend James Hunt is also
being honored here in the 1970s hunt was
Niki Lauda's main rival he was Formula
One world champion in 1976 his son
Freddie hunt is here to keep his
father's memory alive it was his first
race in his last race as far as I'm
aware he never actually finished a race
it I don't know anything he did you
didn't get on with a second vintage
motor cars spanning 50 years of racing
history will compete in seven different
categories for a few hours the
spectators will take a journey back in
time into automotive history
but there's nothing out moated or fusty
about the event the drivers give it all
they've got and push their cars to the
limit to fortunately there's not much by
way of body contact today and the
historic beauties make it through
unscathed
the auto union type c with jacky ickx
also hugs the curves as though time had
stood still the vintage race car still
put out an impressive performance let us
German Formula one winter gay Hardberger
knows the race cars of old and today are
worlds apart when it comes to safety and
comfort he's glad not to be behind the
wheel
I'm sure I would because I think when
you are young and you want to race you
wouldn't care you know but if you look
today and if you would ask me or even
look the other the ball from the wrong
cause if you you won't have a try no
thank you the top it all off there is an
award ceremony a tradition at every
racetrack not just Monte Carlo but here
in Morocco with real French Champagne
victory tastes just a little bit sweeter